hello and welcome to another episode of
biographics I'm your interim host Carl
Smallwood and today we're talking about
Leopold and Loeb The Thrill of the
perfect crime and as always this video
is based on an article provided to us by
our staple of attractive and handsome
writer slash researchers this one being
Radu Alexander links to their socials
can be found below but let's get to it
and soon this involves murder you know
viewer discretion is advised although it
does have a very satisfying ending
because the two mirrors in question were
very stupid
so coffees at the Reddit
the perfect crime is a favorite topic
among mystery writers and television
showrunners who are always coming up
with new and elaborate ways to commit
cunning albeit fictional murders it is
not so much of a conserve for real
criminals as far as most of them go
where Perfect Crime is anyone that they
can get away with there is perhaps
though one notable exception to this
Leopold and Loeb two well-off educated
students who killed the young boy in
1924 because they wanted to commit in
their own words The Perfect Crime it
wasn't murder that excited the duo per
se but the idea of getting away with the
murder that's where the challenge lay as
far as they was concerned a challenge
that as we all know by now they failed
at because we're literally making a
video about how much they sucked at it
and how hard they failed because Leopold
and Loeb were not exactly the criminal
masterminds they thought they were sure
they had high intellects but the
superiority they like to flaunt in
everyone's faces was all in their heads
a smart person does not necessarily
equal a successful criminal and the
pathetic reality is that Leopold and
Loeb only committed a string a passive
vandalism acts and once they moved up to
actual serious crimes they were caught
almost immediately but due to a
sensational trial Nationwide media
coverage in a controversial verdict this
murder was among the slack for you to be
heralded as the crime of the century
ensuring Everlasting notoriety for
Leopold and low which they no doubt very
much enjoyed
foreign
Leopold Jr which is a hell of a mouthful
was born on November 19 1904 in Chicago
Illinois the son of Florence and Nathan
Leopold senior his father was a German
Jewish immigrant who amassed a nice
little Fortune for himself by running a
freight and transport company so no
expense was spared when it came to Young
Nathan's education all of that money
seemed to be well invested since Nathan
Leopold proved to be a child prodigy and
there are numerous examples of his
impressive precociousness but a bit of
skepticism is advised here since most of
the examples come from Leopold's own
autobiography and let's let's face it
not everyone's going to admit to being a
especially not someone like Nathan
Leopold who had a gigantic superiority
complex and was a complete and utter
narcissist in every sense of the word
half a year after Leopold's birth
another wealthy Chicago and family
welcomed their new son into the world
Richard Albert Loeb born on June 11 1906
to Anna Henrietta and Albert Henry Loeb
like his future partner in crime Richard
had a privileged upbringing as his
father was wasn't only a successful
lawyer but a senior executive at Sears
however his Dark Side started
manifesting from a fairly early age as
Loeb enjoyed committing Petty crimes
mainly nicking or thievery as it's known
to Americans and he was only emboldened
when he did not face any serious
consequences for his actions even when
he was caught rich people got a rich
people a few trips The Woodshed might
have saved a lot of people a lot of
grief the two men despite growing up in
the same affluent area of Chicago didn't
really have more than a casual
acquaintance ship with each other for
many years this changed in 1920 when
both boys were skipped a few classes and
sent to the University of Chicago
Leopold was 15 years old while Loeb was
14. both had similar backgrounds and
interests so a friendship naturally
developed between the two however their
partnership almost never got off the
ground because the following year low
transferred to the University of
Michigan there he talked to heavy
drinking and card playing and his grades
started slipping the words wasted
potential no doubt quietly hovering
above his head in his mind but
ultimately Lowe barely managed to
graduate from the University of Michigan
a17 becoming the youngest graduate in
the school's history in 1923 he went
back to University of Chicago to
continue studying for his master's
degree and there he rekindled his
friendship with Nathan Leopold who was
doing the very same thing eventually the
two became lovers as well as friends
they had personalities that complemented
each other very well Lowe was more
outgoing handsome charismatic he
provided the socially awkwardly appalled
with the Thrills and experiences that he
could never accrue on his own meanwhile
the more intellectual Leopold taught His
companion about his life's philosophies
which Loeb ultimately adopted as his own
specifically Leopold became fascinated
with the works of Frederick Nietzsche
particularly the concept of the
Ubermensch or Superman put simply a
Superman was Superior to all of the
average jails around him and was not
bound by the same societal norms and
ethics as Leopold himself would write in
a letter and I quote a Superman is on
account of certain Superior qualities
inherent in him Exempted from the
ordinary laws which govern men he is not
liable for anything he may do you will
surprise you to discover that Nathan
Leopold considered himself to be one of
the Superman due to his intellects and
wouldn't you know it turned out that low
also was a Superman too what are the
odds of that already they had the
makings of their own little Justice
League so what do they decide to do
these little gifts that they had
apparently been blessed with they
committed vandalism of course Richard
Lowe resumed to his life of petty crime
and brought Leopold into the mix often
using sexual favors to persuade him to
join in on the fun even so it didn't
really take that much convincing since
in their minds they were completely
Justified and unaccountable for their
own actions they started out by
committing burglaries stealing cars
smashing Windows well nobody seemed to
give
they moved on to starting fires and once
again evaded any kind of consequences
clearly they were the greatest criminal
masterminds the world had ever seen so
it was time to up their game and carry
out something that would get the whole
city talking
Leopold and low began endlessly
obsessing over committing what they
called The Perfect Crime and they spent
months laboring over their plan
ultimately they decided that they were
not only going to murder someone but
they were going to make it look like a
kidnapping complete with a ransom demand
and a series of complex instructions
though investigators off their Trail
first the victim right who were they
going to kill Leopold and low decided
they needed someone who came from a rich
family so they could pay the ransom and
ideally someone who trusted them because
it would make kidnapping go that much
smoother initially they even thought
about targeting a member of their own
families until deciding against it
because Target is almost so close to
them might arouse suspicion criminal
Geniuses everyone ultimately they left
the identity of their victim to chance
they knew that they would kidnap a boy
from their neighborhood Who Came From a
rich family and went to one of the local
schools would do not know who would be
until the day of the crime itself as an
aside here American film producer Aman
Deutsch has always claimed later in his
life that he had been the intended
target that day but a dentist
appointment saved his life since the
family shelter picked him up and drove
him to the dentist's office on major 21
1924 it was time for Leopold and Loeb to
set their plan in motion they spent
mostly afternoon driving a rental car
around the Kenwood area of Chicago
looking for their victim they spotted
several potential targets and rejected
them all for various arbitrary reasons
around five o'clock they were ready to
call it quits for the day when their
perfect opportunity presented itself to
them in the form of the 14 year old
Bobby Franks walking home alone from
school the circumstances seemed perfect
Bobby was alone his family was rich
enough to pay the ransom and he knew
Richard Loeb so his guard was down on
the car quietly and silently pulled up
alongside him Logan Leopold offered to
give Bobby a ride and the moment the
young boy was in the car and shut the
door his fate was sealed you see
beforehand Logan Leopold had discussed
it and decided that they should commit
The Killing as quickly as possible so
when Bobby Franks looked out of a window
unsuspectingly he was hit in the head
with a chisel his killer struck him
several times without hesitation and
without Mercy but Bobby still held up
the blows caused multiple gashes that
splurted blood everywhere inside the car
the Killer decide to switch tactics so
we forced a piece of cloth down Bobby's
throat keeping his mouth shut until the
young boy suffocated and all signs of
life has left his body the deed was done
although you may have noticed that we
didn't say exactly who did it and that's
because both Loeb and Leopold maintained
to their dying day that it was them who
was driving and the other is the one who
committed the killing and spoilers
that's the one part of their story they
were able to remain consistent on Bobby
Franks was dead well that was just the
first step of their plan now came part
two getting rid of the body The Killers
had their dump site already picked a
marshy Culver near Wolf Lake about 25
miles out of the city it was an area
that Nathan Leopold knew quite well as
he often visited to do a spot for bird
watching they drove around town until it
was dark even stopping for a hot dog at
one point despite having a dead body in
the back seat already the arrogance of
the two killers was evident as in their
minds nothing could possibly go wrong
spoilers it did when night came the duo
took a remote dirt road to Wolf Lake
they stripped Bobby Franks naked and
dumped his body into the Culvert
afterwards they went to loeb's house
disposing murder weapons somewhere along
the way at home they burned all their
bloodstain clothes and then got to work
cleaning the rental car
[Music]
at the Frank's house Bobby's parents
Jacob and Flora had begun to panic when
their son did not show up for dinner
none of his friends our siblings knew
what he was in a search of his school
already revealed that he had not trapped
himself inside or anything like that so
Jacob Franks called a friend of his a
lawyer named Samuel ettleson for
assistance while the two of them were
out Flora Franks received a chilling
phone call from a man claiming to be
George Johnson who told her that her son
had been kidnapped into expecting
instructions in the morning in reality
this was Leopold and Loeb in acting the
third part of their so-called master
plan the kidnapping they thought that
adding this component to their crime
would not only increase the thrill but
obscure their true motive from the
police not to mention give them a little
extra spending money since they intended
to collect their Ransom like idiots they
made the initial call while returning
from Wolf Lake at which point they also
mailed the ransom note which arrived at
the Frank's house the following morning
and as far as Ransom notes go this one
was fairly boilerplate it told them not
to contact the authorities have ten
thousand dollars in small unmapped Bill
ready and two await further instructions
and if all this was done Bobby Franks
will be returned on hand little did the
parents know that their son was already
dead while Jacob Franks was getting the
money Samuel ettleson alerted the
Chicago PD that Bobby Franks had been
kidnapped this was all supposed to be
Hush Hush but a journalist found out
about it probably after being tipped off
by a source inside the police department
itself like any good news hound he was
up to date with all the goings on in the
city and he'd also heard about the body
of a boy that had been recently found
near Wolf Lake that was being treated as
a possible drowning victim he may have
been the very first person to connect
the dots between the two events and he
told the police who then told Jacob
Franks Franks reacted exactly like you'd
expect a heartbroken father to react see
it couldn't be Bobby he said the
description of the body did not match
him it wouldn't make any sense for the
kidnappers to kill him these were all
justifications of a desperate man who
was clinging on to the hope their son
was still alive but while Jacob Franks
waited to receive a new call from the
kidnapper his brother-in-law went to
view the body at around 1pm the
following day George Johnson filmed
again Samuel Edison answered the call
and the kidnapper gave him the following
instructions getting a cab that would
arrive shortly and go to a certain
drugstore where you'd receive receive
another car ethelson then passed the
phone to Jacob Franks who received the
same instructions however in all the
excitement both men immediately forgot
the address of the drugstore so when the
taxi arrived neither one knew exactly
where to go and neither did the cabbie
Not only would matter because right
before leaving Jacob Franks received
another found car this one wasn't the
kidnapper it was much worse than that it
was from his brother-in-law who called
to tell him that the dead boy found a
wolf link was indeed his son
Leopold on low was starting to realize
at this point that this whole murder
business wasn't as easy as they'd
assumed it was the killing was far more
violent and chaotic than they'd expected
the kidnapping didn't go anywhere
because the body was discovered almost
immediately and as you will soon find
out the disposal was the worst decision
of all and the one thing that would
ultimately seem the two of the alleged
criminal masterminds and it's worth
pointing out as well in the original
article I'm reading from like Master
criminals is put in Big Air quotes which
I very much appreciate unsurprisingly
the murder of a young boy from an
affluent neighborhood became the biggest
topic of discussion in Chicago and the
state's attorney Robert Crowe taught
personal charge of the investigation
smelling a nice big promotion at the end
of it the first lead came from The
Ransom now investigators determined that
it had been written on an Underwood
typewriter by an intelligent and
well-educated man this would have been
the perfect occasion to try and lead the
authorities Australia by forging the
English a bit and making it sound like
the kidnapper was an ordinary criminal
but Leopold and lobes egos would not
have allowed that they could never
refuse the opportunity to show off their
Flex even when it was against their own
interests so of course Leopold typed the
ransom note out in perfect English using
long fantasy words that proudly showed
off his higher education and legal
expertise what a
that was Leopold's Folly but low was no
better he was so arrogant and confident
that he thought he'd be fun to
investigate his own cry with some of his
fraternity Brothers including a reporter
for the daily news everyone knew about
the failed kidnapping plot so the 19
year old Loeb and a few other students
tried to track down the drugstore where
Jacob Franks was supposed to go to see
if they could find any clues at one
point the reporter even asked Lowe if he
knew the victims which Lowes smiled and
said and I quote if I were going to
murder anybody I would murder just such
a cocky little son of a as Bobby Franks
criminal masterminds everybody it's like
they couldn't help themselves Leopold
and lo were just two egomaniacs who
couldn't resist the temptation to show
off how Superior they thought they were
to everybody else and insert themselves
into the investigation they thought they
were so distinct and special and it's
almost amusing how cliche they really
were on the other side of the law the
police already had Nathan Leopold's name
since he had been spotted around Wolf
Lake several times by the game warden
yeah don't don't body somewhere that you
frequent you you idiot they interviewed
him but because he was an established
ornithologist he did have a valid reason
to go to Wolf Lake on bird watching
Expeditions plus he came from a rich and
respected family and no one thought that
someone like him would commit such a
heinous and violent crime not yet anyway
the police bought Leopold's story for
the time being but eight days after the
murder they caught their biggest break
in the case next to Bobby Frank's Body
they found a pair of glasses which have
fallen out of Leopold's pocket while
carrying the body the prescription was
very common so it wasn't exactly a
passport photo so the police didn't
think anything would come of it but when
they checked them out anyway they hit
Pay Dirt specifically the hinges of the
glasses were very distinct in only one
place in all of Chicago supplied them
they only sold three pairs one of them
was to Nathan Leopold so it was time to
take off the kid gloves but the police
still didn't want Leopold to think they
suspected him they even booked him a
room at a fancy hotel for their
interview so they could have a little
discretion away from the prying eyes the
Press what Leopold did not know though
is that Richard Lowe was being
interviewed in literally the room next
door for the most part the two of them
stuck to the same story they spent most
of their day driving around town in
Leopold's car eating drinking and bird
watching at night they engage in some
bird watching of an altogether different
kind and picked up two girls and drove
around some more and end of the night by
driving to Leopold's aunt and uncle's
help which initially sounded fairly
reasonable to investigators and with the
gift of hindsight very well rehearsed
the problem was though is that Loeb and
Leopold didn't do anything to actually
corroborate this so when the
investigators realized that the majority
of their Alibi hinged on the fact they
done a lot of driving they thought well
let's go ask the family show first and
when asked he said he'd worked on Nathan
Leopold's car all day long and just like
that the entire Alibi crumbled when
presented with the facts low was the
first to crack and he told the police
everything just 10 days after the
would-be Perfect Crime occurred he ended
his confession with an attempt to pass
the blame onto Leopold saying in part I
just want to say that I offer No Escape
explain fully convinced that neither the
idea nor the ACT would have occurred to
me if it not being for the suggestion
and stimulus of Leopold furthermore I do
not believe that I would have been
capable of killing Franks
suffice to say that the arrest and
Triumph of Leopold on low caused a bit
of a palava shout out to the author for
using one of my favorite archaic words
becoming one of the first few examples
to referred to as the trail of the
century in papers the families of
Leopold and low hired one of the best
lawyers in the country Clarence Darrow
the man who would defend teacher John
Scopes in the Scopes Monkey Trial a year
later Leopold on Loeb had already
pleaded guilty on Darrow's
recommendation this way the trial turned
into a sentencing hearing and the lawyer
only had to argue from the judge is that
of a jury who'd be more likely to side
against the two young men who openly
admitted to murdering a child his one
goal then was to prevent his clients
from having a date with the hangman's
noose and he did this by bringing in
several psychiatrists or alienists as
they were called back then to testify on
the mental state of the accused he also
brought to their age admissions of guilt
neglect and even sexual abuse Leopold
may have suffered at the hands of his
governess when he was a kid basically he
was just throwing a wall see what would
stick to create some kind of mitigating
circumstances for Leopold and low Darrow
ended the hearing with a two-hour long
speech variously described as masterful
and the finest of his career which I
will now reproduce for you in its
entirety
no it was a plea for Mercy basically an
attack on the capital punishment itself
and an argument that the sentence should
be Reformatory not retribute sorry
whatever he said he persuaded the judge
who sent us Leopold and lobe to life in
prison for murder plus 99 years for the
kidnapping and that was the end of the
criminal careers of Leopold and Loeb the
two of them stayed friends on the inside
and even started a school for prisoners
in 1932 at Statesville Penitentiary
however low was killed in 1936 by his
cellmate James E day who cut him with a
straight razor over 60 times possibly
after low propositioned him for sex
Nathan Leopold was actually paroled in
1958 after 33 years in prison seemingly
a reformed man he no longer thought
himself as a Superman or ubermensch
instead calling himself a humble little
person he moved to Puerto Rico in search
of obscurity where he continues studying
Birds he got his master's degree he
found a job and he even married he died
of a heart attack in 1971. so thank you
for tuning in to this episode of
biographics as mentioned at the start
I've been your host Carl Smallwood yes
that is my real name and this video is
based on original article provided tours
by Radu Alexander links to all of our
socials can be found below as always if
you like this video leave a like if
you've got something to say about it
leave a comment in particular I would
like feedback on my hosting and
presentation style I'm trying to strike
a balance between the altogether more
formal and let's admit better
presentation style of my esteemed
predecessor Simon Whistler and my own
more casual relaxed style which you can
see on my own channels back theme with
Kyle Smallwood and Wiki weekends so let
me have any feedback about that and I'll
try and like deal with it and respond to
it as best as I'm able to otherwise if
you want to see more videos like this
subscribe for more and as always have
the day you all deserve chess